[Music]
notes up guys I get the HD here
welcome to the smartphone Awards 2019
I'm your host marques Brownlee and
welcome to the show
so 2019 was a really interesting year
for smartphones in a lot of ways I think
it's really easy to forget that and so
we've got a ton of smart phones almost
desks in front of me as is tradition all
of which came out during near 2019 and
some of these are gonna win some awards
today so for those of you who are new
here and there's plenty of you the way
this works is we have a bunch of
categories and each category will get an
overall winner which has a trophy
associated with it and if there's a
worthy one will have a runner-up and
possibly some honorable mentions so
without any further ado let's just get
right into it so the first award of the
night is for best big phone
now almost every phone on this desk is
probably bigger than every phone from
the desk the way it would have looked
five years ago but this award is for the
one that makes the best use of that
extra space that has the best big phone
features and I have a certain favorite
in mind the best big phone for 2019 it's
gonna go to the asus rog phone - so this
phone absolutely crushed in the spec
Department and that was no surprise but
there also a ton of other big phone
features that I loved about it - so
obviously snapdragon a 55 12 gigs of ram
we've all seen that
but then the huge high res 120 Hertz
OLED display on the front with no notch
we got dual front-facing speakers we
have a headphone jack in this phone a
dual camera setup on the back and to top
it all off they tossed in a gigantic
6,000 milliamp hour battery you know
this is a gaming phone this is the
second generation of the ROG phones that
came out this year and a lot of these
features and specs that keep saying are
to make the gaming experience better
you know the dual front-facing speakers
is to make for better gaming the high
refresh rate huge OLED display is to
make better gaming the huge battery
better gaming but all of these things
like I've said in the review also
contribute to making an awesome media
experience and just an overall great
smartphone so best overall big phone for
sure this year but I have an honorable
mention or a sort of runner-up my
runner-up for best big phone of the year
is one that's perennial II been one of
best uses of big phone space for a while
now not a lot of phones can have a
stylus and a 4000 million power plus
battery you already know what I'm
talking about
that's gonna be the Galaxy Note 10 huge
battery big phone features big phone
design and a stylus on top of it all
they got rid of the headphone jack but
that's maybe the only complaint about
the way they put this thing together but
like I said best overall big phone for
2019 that award goes to the asus rog
phone - alright so the next category is
best compact smartphone and I've sort of
mentioned this before but probably every
phone on this desk is bigger than every
phone from five years ago there's some
phones on here that came out this year
where the screen itself is bigger than
the whole phone for previous years but
that hasn't stopped some manufacturers
from still focusing on a relatively
compact smartphone experience this is
all about the best use of small space
and so my winner for the best compact
smartphone for 2019 is this guy this is
the samsung galaxy s 10 e the S 10 he
kind of flew on the radar for a lot of
us this year it came out alongside the S
10 and s 10 plus but this was the less
expensive version of that phone that
made almost no sacrifices the things
that did leave out were in my opinion
the less important 3rd telephoto camera
and then it also moved the fingerprint
reader from under the glass to the thumb
button which on a smaller phone is
actually much easier to reach and it was
a really really fast one so it was
convenient didn't feel like a loss of
course you still have that pole punch
cut out in the top right hand corner
still an awesome display still high in
specs still good battery life and on top
of all that it kept the headphone jack
which was pretty great for a lot of
people so the Galaxy S 10 II that's
gonna be my pick for best compact phone
of the year but there is a runner up as
well and it's a phone that's perennial
II over and over again one of the ones
that makes the least sacrifices between
the small version and the big version of
the phone you probably already know what
I'm talking about
that's the iPhone 11 Pro really the only
difference between the iPhone 11 Pro and
the 11 Pro max the bigger version is
smaller battery smaller screen
everything else the same cameras the
same specs the same software all the
same features are all this
on the iPhone this is a legitimate
flagship at a smaller size and a smaller
price than the bigger phone so in a
world war most phones these days are
much bigger than any of their previous
and brothers were we got some good ones
but yes the overall winner for compact
smartphone of the year for 2019 is a
samsung galaxy s 10 II all right the
next award category is best smartphone
camera and this is probably my favorite
category I'm probably a little biased
because I love cameras clearly but hey
it's my show so I get to be a bit biased
there were a bunch of really good and
really interesting smartphone cameras
that came out this year we also had our
blind smartphone camera test as I guess
tradition now this one didn't win that
but it is in my opinion the best and
most versatile overall smartphone camera
and that's gonna go to the iPhone 11 Pro
and iPhone 11 Pro max that's for two
reasons number one it has multiple focal
lengths it has the ultra wide camera as
a standard camera and the telephoto and
number two for prowess in both photos
and videos on all three cameras it's
kind of funny we've always had this
thought that iPhones are usually either
at the best or some of the best
smartphone cameras on the market the
competition definitely caught up but
this year the iPhone 11 pro took some of
the biggest steps forward over the
previous year and that's especially in
the image processing department we're
talking the new low light mode we're
talking better portrait mode the
computational photography movement has
been LED in the last two years or so and
the iPhone is right near the front of
that now and especially that versatility
now I'm gonna give a runner up and it's
- one that I actually think typically
takes to me slightly better photos than
the iPhone 11 pro but that's in some
situations I'm talking about Google
pixel 4 and it's not going to be my
winner because it doesn't take very good
videos doesn't have the best microphone
in the world and it doesn't have an
ultra wide camera but the photos that it
takes for the most part are typically a
little bit contrast e'er punch here in
my opinion they feel more confident in a
way but either way computational
photography again a very strong point
and one of the best parts of this phone
pixel for is my runner-up for best
smartphone camera of the year and if
I'm going to give an honorable mention
or two here one to the huawei mate 30
Pro I got this one later in the year and
it didn't come to the US and I haven't
even reviewed it but I did like taking
photos with it often very sharp very
detailed photos you have a quad camera
set up on the back here maybe leave a
comment below if you think this is worth
its own review but I like this a lot and
another shout out to another honorable
mention and that is the blind smartphone
camera test winner from this year which
was Samsung Galaxy Note 10
so those are your smartphone notables in
the camera Department and the winner
overall for best camera for 2019 is the
iPhone 11 pro okay so the next up
category is battery best smartphone
battery for 2019 and this one's pretty
simple you just have to have the best
battery life or the best combination of
battery and fast charging or wireless
charging whatever the solution is it's
got to give the best power experience
and I didn't have much of a choice for
this one my best battery life for 2019
and any smart phone is gonna go to the
asus rog phone to this one like i said
had a six thousand milliamp hour battery
which is pretty much part one to the
recipe for any great smart phone battery
it doesn't have wireless charging and it
has decently fast charging but also if
you turn the refresh rate of this 120
Hertz OLED down to 90 Hertz you were
getting like a day and a half out of
this thing and if you turn it down to 60
Hertz which you probably never would
really want to but if you had to you
could get two days of battery out of
this phone easily confidently which I
cannot say about any other phone here
this had the best battery of any phone
that I've used in a long time now I have
a runner-up for this category as well
and that's gonna go to a phone that
really takes advantage of having a very
low power draw display and just crank
and battery and it's even better than it
was last year I'm talking of course
about the iPhone 11 successor to the
already incredible battery life version
iPhone 10 R this is like the middle
child in the iPhone family great battery
life from an iPhone and we love to see
that and I'm gonna give an honorable
mention as well to this isn't the best
battery life in any phone
but this is gonna go to the fastest
charging phone that I've ever seen that
the world has ever seen because it's the
fastest one you've ever had and that is
the Oppo Reno ace they might not have
heard of this phone it's not the biggest
baddest flagship from Oppo this year but
they did include what they're calling
what's called super vogue 2.0 it's 65
watt fast charging and that'll bring
this battery from zero dead to a hundred
percent full in about thirty minutes
which is incredible and so there's a
couple over smart phones that had forty
five hundred five thousand milliamp hour
batteries pretty big ones but those are
your winners those are your notables in
the battery department for this year
with the best overall battery going to
the asus rog phone - alright so the next
category is the design award and this
sort of has shifted over the past couple
years you know sometimes the design
award is the best build quality and a
phone or maybe it should just mean like
the best overall nicest design with the
least compromises maybe there's some
other ways to think about it but we're
going back to our roots here with a
design award and this is gonna go to
what I think is the most important
design of this year and that's this guy
it's the samsung galaxy fold so this is
a fun one and I think I have no doubt in
my head this is the most interesting
phone to come out during this year and
potentially we'll look back at it as the
most important so of course the first
galaxy fold that never actually shipped
to customers ended up breaking mine was
one of those but that one ever actually
sold the one that actually came out a
couple months later the version two that
did actually saw the customers was
around two thousand dollars it was not
very popular it didn't sell a whole ton
but it's of course a first of its kind I
think when you look around at the other
phones that came out this year all of
which had their own merits for being
great in their own ways this one was one
of the only ones that gave you the
possibility of putting a bigger screen
in your pocket in the same footprint and
that concept that I'm looking forward to
seeing in generation 2 and generation 3
of and looking forward to seeing other
companies takes of was one of the most
fascinating parts of looking at smart
phones this year and I think a lot of
other people would agree with that
especially when you look at the
landscape of phones we have now so I
love the concept I love the the risk
that they took and
execution was not bad I reviewed it we
can go back and watch that but that's
the design Award winner but I do also
have a runner-up and that's - a phone
that also came out this year and didn't
necessarily take big risks but was a
nice fresh take on something that I
really like to see and that is the
smaller version here of the Samsung
Galaxy Note 10 year we got a note 10
plus and a note 10 this smaller one is
the first note that they've made that
you can really reach the entire screen
at once it still has that stylus in it
it still has that sweet or a glow look
and the awesome display and the boxy
shape and the little hole punch cut out
so Galaxy Note 10 my runner up in the
design department so two times Samsung
they're in that category but the winner
overall for design award for 2019 is a
Samsung Galaxy fold okay so next up is
the budget phone category the best
budget phone of the year now it's funny
we look at smart phones and yes one of
the themes is they've gotten much more
expensive over the course of the last
year - we have thousand-dollar phones we
have 1500 $2,000 phones here but we're
actually looking at one of the most
competitive categories yet for this one
I think the top two could easily be
interchangeable but my winner for best
budget phone for 2019 is gonna go to
this guy right here the redmi k20 pro so
there are a couple different variants of
this phone that came out in different
markets but this one started at $2.99
and that was one of the biggest things I
raved about in the review and that was
sort of a natural feeling was wow you
get some serious high-end specs you get
a big notch list display you get a pop
up camera you still get a headphone jack
and you get a triple camera setup on the
back and a pretty decent sized battery
for a such a low price for a fraction of
the cost of a lot of other phones so a
lot of people that bought this phone
this year really liked it and it was a
sort of a phantom successor to the
infamous poco phone from last year but
it's not alone in this category for
being really really good for the price
I'm gonna hang on to this and pick up my
runner-up almost like their Co winners
because they're really that close and
could go either way
but my runner-up for best budget phone
of 2019
Google's pixel three a and this was a
$400 phone at launch and this took a
very different approach to what the
balance was for features for the price
what the pixel really focused on was an
incredible camera had the same camera as
the pixel three which one our camera
award from last year and also of course
the stock Google experience had a lot of
the same benefits of any other pixel
quick software updates pure Google
experience the build quality wasn't
necessarily amazing but you still got
the headphone jack you got a pretty
decent battery and it was a lot of what
people were looking for and just a
simple inexpensive phone these two
phones were great this year and I do
have some other honorable mentions but
as far as the best of the best for
budget phones the $300
redmi k20 pro and the 400 are pixel 3ei
were pretty sweet I'm also gonna bring
up the 1 + 7 T and this was a more
expensive phone is's around the $700
mark but this was giving you all the
same performance and features and speed
as those thousand-dollar phones and was
consistently looked at as some of the
best bang for the buck in a smartphone
world for all of this year and I'm also
gonna give a shout out to the Motorola
one hyper this is actually a late
edition came out just a few weeks ago
this year but this is also a really
great phone for 400 bucks has gotten a
review yet but that may also be worth
reviewing if you guys are into that in
the comments section but that's been it
a lot of great competition in the budget
area this year and that sort of stratify
as this world the smartphones where now
you have stuff going from $300 to $2,300
and you start to see the differences
more but the overall winner for budget
phone for 2019
was your redmi k20 pro all right bust of
the year and you hate to give out a
negative award at an award show right
but there's always some pillars that
stick out about a year smartphones that
are disappointments and that our phones
you shouldn't buy so we do have a bust
of the year for 2019 now I will preface
this by saying the sentiment about a
phone is not necessarily just about how
good or bad that phone is it often also
takes
to account how good that phone could
have been the expectations for what a
phone might have been and is capable of
being - reality you can probably see
where I'm going with this the bus of the
year for 2019 it is the Google pixel for
see the pixel for is not necessarily at
all the worst phone you can buy it's not
the worst phone on this desk but it did
have the biggest Delta between what
people expected of a new pixel and what
she actually got so with a new pixel we
of course all know to expect a great
camera and the latest and greatest of
the Google software experience and we
did get that but they started off the
bat within pretty underwhelming design
with that forehead and then we started
having problems we had the 90 Hertz
issues we had the battery problems that
came with that we had motion sense not
being very good and then of course there
was no ultra wide camera there is no 4k
60 in video mode there's not a very good
microphone and just you combine all
these things on top of a launch price
which was around $900 it sort of spoke
out to the world that it's competing
against all these other high-end
flagships but it didn't deliver on a lot
of the things that we expect from a
high-end flagship so the pixel is a
really great camera and it's sort of a
phone that's gonna go under the radar
because of the things that it was a let
down on but because of that Delta
between what we expected from a new
pixel and what we got that's the bust of
the year now I also do have a runner up
for bust of the year and it's just a
straight-up bad phone it's a phone you
shouldn't buy it's a phone that almost
shouldn't have existed I first saw it at
CES where it became very clear that they
were just rushing to come out with the
first of its kind the first folding
phone and I finally did come out and it
never should have this is a the Royal
flex PI I kind of feel bad for anyone
who actually bought one of these this
phone clearly still looks and feels like
a prototype of a folding display that
doesn't necessarily have aimed to be
used by real people but you could get
one and that's about all I can say about
it is you could get one and it wasn't
very good
not a great battery not a great
camera not a great OS or software
experience not a great design not a
great look or feel in the hand even
putting it in your pocket like this is
not a comfortable phone to use or hold
with one hand or to open or closed
nothing good about the Royal flexpay not
even gonna cheer coat that one this is
my fav runner-up for it's not like we
expected this to be good
but really it's just a bad overall phone
so that's my runner-up but the bust of
the year overall for 2019 is the Google
pixel for okay back to the positive
Awards the next up category is the most
improved award and I love a Most
Improved Player this is always a story
that's fun when you see something come
out last year and you don't necessarily
have high hopes for the new one and then
BOOM big strides forward big
improvements you love to see that and so
my winner for most improved award for
2019 is gonna go to this guy asus rog
phone - this is i think third trophy of
the night races so a little mini round
of applause there the reason this is
winning the most improved award this is
the second generation in their gaming
phones from the ROG phone one the reason
this is most improved is not just
because the specs you know of course
they nailed the specs you have a huge
battery you have the new hundred twenty
Hertz OLED and you have the Snapdragon a
55 plus and all that fun stuff but the
reason it's most improved is because
they take a legitimate risk with the
software experience well some might not
say risk this is a suggestion that I
gave to them from the first one but a
lot of people including me said that
that Zen UI on the first ROG phone was a
little bit over the top and they heard
us and in this ROG phone you have the
choice between that Zen UI or a much
cleaner standard version of Android and
I give you that choice out the box and
for the entire life that you use this
phone you can choose between the two and
that was them listening and responding
to some real feedback and that made this
phone much better for me I could use
this phone daily and loved it every
single day a camera's not that great and
maybe the one most improved again and
improved the camera but I really like
what they did with the software on the
ROG phone too so that is why it's gotten
the most improved award and its third
piece of hardware of the night but I do
of course have a runner-up for this
category and
and I think flies under the radar for
the improvements that they typically
make and that's gonna go to iPhone 11
Pro the reason this wins the runner up
for most improved is because of the
cameras the new camera suite you get the
new lenses the new perspectives the new
improved quality and the big battery
gains from the iPhone 10s to the 11 and
the 11 Promax having the biggest battery
gains of them all so them getting rid of
3d touch was a big reason for that but
big time battery gains and big time
camera gains are important places to
have gains and that's why they have a
most improved runner up but the of
course winner for the most improved
award for 2019 is that asus rog phone -
so that brings us to the end which is
the big award of the night the big
trophy over there this is the MVP it's a
smart phone of the year for 2019 and
those again now some big pillars
standing here there's important phones
there's important designs there's
improvements being made left and right
we have a big choice to make for smart
phone of the year and this doesn't
necessarily go to the best overall smart
phone that you should buy right now but
this goes to one that has I think the
best combination of all its attributes
that came out this year in a bunch of
different departments so I'm talking
about my winner which is the oneplus 7
pro this phone is my MVP my smart phone
of the year by all accounts the oneplus
7 pro was the most liked smartphone of
the year it was followed up later in the
year by the 70 and a 70 pro which didn't
come to the US but the oneplus 7 pro
that kicked those all off felt like the
best most complete smartphone of the
year so had the Snapdragon a 55
top-of-the-line
tons of RAM the specs were great then
you have a full screen high-res AMOLED
display with no notch thanks for the
pop-up selfie camera the cameras I think
being the worst part of the phone is a
good thing to say because they're not
that bad they're below what you'd find
in like a thousand-dollar phone but
they're pretty ok and then a solid
battery very fast charging a great
software experience from oneplus and
then 90 Hertz 90 Hertz is really where
this phone started to separate itself
because now we're starting to see a
divide between smart phones
don't have hire fresh rate and
smartphones that do and it's becoming
this thing to follow how low does it get
in price or where do we see these 90
Hertz displays popping up and I think
next year you're gonna start to see a
lot of the ones that didn't get on the
bandwagon get on that bandwagon it might
be the year of 90 120 Hertz screens in
phones but this is where that started
and this really proved that that
experience does matter and on top of all
that this was not a thousand dollar
phone this one dropped in below eight
hundred bucks
so it was undercutting them in price
proving you don't have to spend a
thousand bucks to get a really great
smartphone experience in a lot of ways
it was a better smartphone experience
than some of the more expensive ones so
this is the phone I use for a good
amount of this year I am now using its
sequel the 70 Pro the predecessor or the
successor but that is my MVP that is
gonna be the winner for smart phone of
the year for 2019 but I do have some
runner ups and that's the galaxy fold
again one of the most interesting phones
in a really long time and sort of
proving that this is the beginning of a
potentially long line of new form
factors and then I have some honorable
mentions of course I want to give a
shout out again to the pixel 3a as a
potential smart phone of the year this
for a lot of people is a great reason to
buy a phone that's less than 400 bucks
I hope the pixel for a continues and
picks up with a three I left off I'm
also give a shout-out to the iPhone 11
Pro taking major strides forward in a
lot of areas now I'm still really
looking forward to the 2020 iPhone but
the games we made with camera and
battery make this I think the most
worthy of a pro name in any of the smart
phones we have that came out this year
so iPhone 11 Pro is gonna get that
honorable mention for MVP but of course
the winner for most valuable player most
viable smartphone is gonna go to the
oneplus 7 pro and so that's it those are
your awards for 2019 I think maybe when
we started this and we look back at you
know all the phones that came out this
year it's really easy to see them all as
this uniform of all these glass
sandwiches but now it's more clear than
ever that there's something for everyone
still there's something whether you're
interested in cameras or the best
possible big phone or you want to
compact
phone where you have to have the best
battery experience whatever it is it's
really hard to buy a bad new phone now
in 2019 there are even phones on this
desk that didn't win awards that are
still really good in a lot of ways so
I'm happy about the choices we've gotten
and I'm pretty happy with the awards so
the tradition lives on if any of the
companies that did win awards want their
actual physical trophy I am more than
willing to ship that out to them over
the holidays but that's been it for the
award show I'm your host marques
Brownlee this has been my Awards for the
best smartphones of 2019 thanks for
watching catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]